je relancerai une vraie politique
familiale pour refaire de la famille
piles et damnation valérie pécresse et
la candidate qui soutiendra le pouvoir
d'achat des familles pour relancer la
natalité nous rétablirons l'universalité
des allocations familiales elles seront
versées sans condition de ressources
pour toutes les familles ces 900 euros
par an dès le premier enfant nous
augmenterons les allocations familiales
à partir du deuxième enfant et pour tous
les parents nous baisserons le taux de
tva sur les couches à 2,1 pour cent pour
concilier vie familiale et vie
professionnelle
nous garantirons aux parents des
solutions de garde nous donnerons aux
parents les moyens de choisir le mode de
garde de leurs enfants en rendant
accessible à tous les parents sans
aucune condition de ressources le
complément de libre choix de mode de
garde nous soutiendrons la garde
d'enfants en milieu rural en lançant un
programme national pour la petite
enfance afin de mieux répondre aux
besoins des familles en milieu rural
nous augmentons les plafonds de crédit
d'impôt pour les emplois à domicile en
particulier pour la garde d'enfants les
aidants familiaux seront reconnus à leur
juste valeur avec un véritable statut et
des congés spéciaux avec valérie
pécresse nous protégerons les familles
monoparentales ou défiscalisent rond les
pensions alimentaires des pères et des
mères seules parce que cet argent doit
d'abord bénéficié à l'enfant
nous fixerons la pension de reversions
pour les veuves et les veufs à 75 %
contre 54 % seulement aujourd'hui nous
des conjugale is wrong l'allocation pour
adulte handicapé pour ne pas pénaliser
les bénéficiaires qui vivent en couple
et risquent de perdre leurs allocations